corse le blocus est entièrement levées
les représentants syndicaux sont à paris
les négociations commenceront demain les
paradoxes de la nouvelle donne syndicale
menacé brettés seul grand syndicat signé
l'accord sur l'aménagement du temps de
travail
jean kaspar s'en expliquera élections
législatives dimanche prochain en union
soviétique élections à la mode
gorbatchev
elles sont aussi la mesure des tendances
nationalistes
reportage en azerbaïdjan le combat d'un
vieil homme pour la mémoire et pour la
justice simon wiesenthal chasseur de
nazis ce soir apostrophes et dans ce
journal
formule 1 le premier grand prix de la
saison à rio dimanche prochain la france
à l'honneur avec le retour des moteurs
renault bas monsieur bonsoir la
situation s'améliore en corse le blocus
est totalement levé ce soir les liaisons
vont donc être progressivement rétablies
avec l'îlot prix sans doute d'une
certaine confusion dans les aéroports et
dans les ports les syndicats de la
fonction publique toujours en grève ont
négocié dans la journée avec les préfets
à ajaccio et à bastia et ils ont
finalement accepté de se rendre à paris
gérard leclerc vous propose que nous
rencontrions le négociateur dès demain
cris de victoire après 3 heures
d'ultimes tractations avec le préfet de
bastia et 24 heures de tergiversations
se sont succédé réunion conciliabules
coups de téléphone et manifestations les
sept organisations ont obtenu d'être
reçus ensemble demain après midi par le
directeur de la fonction publique
ils discuteront de la vie chère en corse
et de la création de primes de transport
mais ce n'est qu'à leur retour dans
l'île qu'ils décideront mardi avec la
base des suites du mouvement dans l'île
une certaine détente se confirme malgré
la grève des administrations cargo et
car ferries ont pu accoster normalement
dans les aéroports tous les vols sont
assurés sauf un bastia perturbée par une
grève du personnel au sol cgt cinq
semaines de grève dans la fonction
publique
d'une semaine de blocus et d'isolement
de lille ce sont les professionnels du
tourisme corse qui sont maintenant à
quai le week-end de pâques s'annonce
plutôt mal nicolas jacobs philippe dumas
le soir deux clients deviendront sa
table est ici de clients seulement
qu'ils pourront ensuite choisir entre
les 58 chambres de cet hôtel d'ajaccio
le grand luxe et le grand calme trop
calme
nous étions complets a continué 13 et
nous sommes aujourd'hui est complètement
vide
l'hôtel toutes les réservations étaient
annulées ça a des répercussions
catastrophiques sur seulement dans le
présent est immédiat mais pour le mois
d'avril et peut-être pour la saison il
est sûr que les touristes seront rares
en corse pendant les vacances de pâques
les étrangers en particulier les
italiens les suisses les allemands ont
préféré annulé leur séjour depuis hier
la situation se débloque une dizaine
d'avions se sont posés depuis sur
l'aéroport d'ajaccio et le trafic
revient à la normale
les professionnels du tourisme reste
serein la vraie saison n'a pas encore
commencé
c'est la conséquence d'un phénomène
purement mécanique c'est à dire
finalement les touristes comment pas eu
la possibilité de venir nous espérons
que il n'y aura pas d'impact durable
image de la corse je pense que à brève
échéance la situation se rétablira quel
est l'impact exact du blocus sur
l'industrie du tourisme corse c'est
encore impossible à dire
les gens chargés de le calculer sont en
grève et les fonctionnaires en grève
attend donc le début des négociations
demain entre leurs représentants
syndicaux et le directeur de la fonction
publique à paris la base semble
déterminé à maintenir le mouvement il
est vrai qu'en corse avec l'aide du
village de la famille on peut tenir
longtemps
françois joly et dominique berlin l'ont
vérifié à bastia au hasard d'une
rencontre
j'ai 40 ans je suis marié j'ai trois
enfants ma femme travaille pas je suis
dessinateur au service du cadastre
depuis 20 ans je touche 6800 francs et
je suis en grève actuellement depuis
cinq semaines
en corse la situation vécue en interne
un coup dur les amis sont là pour
soutenir la famille puisse les amis moi
le matin quand j'arrive
j'ai un panier et je le montrerai ma
mère et elle y met ce qu'elle veut dans
la situation actuelle
surpris au panier il a augmenté de
volume avant j'y allais
occasionnellement mélanger voiture tous
les matins j'ai un cousin qui est qui
qui vend du poisson à moi et
et je peux aller prendre un poisson on
ne dira pas on dira pas non parce qu'il
sait que si julien le solliciter c'est
que je n'ai jamais vraiment de juin
j'ai un ami qui m'a donné l'an d'europe
je n'ai pas encore regardé j'ai juste je
ne sais pas si je vais l'ouvrir et je ne
sais pas ce qui est dedans mais voilà ma
connaissance
dans le cas où on aurait besoin jusqu'à
présent mans
cette solidarité de la famille à cacher
beaucoup de choses
c'est par là
la mère qui me séparent c'est carrément
en océan sépare de paris et je sais pas
si à paris on se rend bien compte de la
situation mais je peux vous assurer que
je suis plus déterminé que jamais la
corse encore avec un très intéressant
sondage que publiera demain le provençal
un sondage sur 600 personnes résidant en
corse et qui met à mal la classe
politique corses 28% des personnes
interrogées contre 52 estiment qu'elle
joue convenablement son rôle 28%
seulement les syndicats sont mieux
perçues 52% apprécié leur action contre
20% qui s'en méfient le jeu des
syndicats sur la question corse est
difficile les directions nationales ne
sont pas forcément à l'unisson des
représentants locaux
alors qu'en est-il à la cfdt jean kaspar
bonsoir bonsoir vous en êtes le nouveau
patron est ce que vous êtes vous
favorable à la prime d'insularité que
que réclament les fonctionnaires cfdt
dans ligne non c'est pas la bonne
solution
nous avons effectivement proposé avec
l'accord d'ailleurs de l'union régionale
cfdt corse la création d'une prime
représentant le différentiel d'inflation
avec la l'évolution des prix et du
continent et si effectivement le
différentiel de l'inflation se réduit la
prime ressort et du ray et si
l'inflation en corse évolué de la même
manière que dans notre pays
cette prime disparaîtrait car il faut
s'attaquer aux mécanismes même de
l'inflation en corse et nous pensons
qu'une prime d'un sale
le prix mix particulière serait
effectivement le mauvaise formule et ça
vous pensez que c'est un langage que les
gens syndiqué cfdt dans la fonction
publique encore sont prêts à entendre ce
soir à tout à fait parce que cette
position est celle de notre union
régionale cfdt corse
oui nous sommes en profond d'accord avec
cette position c'est cette position qui
a été produit par la cfdt en corse
alors revenons en maintenant jean kaspar
à l'accord que vous avez signés avec le
patronat sur l'aménagement du temps de
travail
deux syndicats seulement l'ont signée
vous et la cgc alors vraiment c'est le
monde à l'envers
vous signez force ouvrière refuse ainsi
que la cgt c'est vous en quelque sorte
qu'ils prenaient la relève d'andré
bergeron écouter non on prend la place
de personne ce que nous regardons c'est
la réalité la réalité c'est le fait
qu'aujourd'hui la modernisation se fait
dans n'importe quelles conditions
sans prendre en compte le volet social
ce que l'on constate c'est que les 10
heures supplémentaires se développe de
plus en plus alors qu'il y à peine plus
de deux millions et demi de chômeurs ce
que l'on constate c'est que la précarité
se développe
l'insécurité de l'emploi est ce que l'on
constate également c'est que aujourd'hui
sur le terrain dans les entreprises se
réalise l'aménagement du temps de
travail sans contrepartie pour les
salariés
lorsque nous avons voulu faire à travers
cet accord s'est imposé des règles du
jeu des règles du jeu au patronat dans
un accord interprofessionnel qui renvoie
des négociations au niveau des branches
c'est à dire au niveau des professions
c'est à dire la métallurgie le textile
la chimie etc pour que le patronat
comprennent qu'on ne peut pas aménager
le temps de travail sans contrepartie
pour les salariés qu'on ne peut pas
moderniser sans prendre en compte la
dimension sociale
je crois que nous avons eu une attitude
responsable et cela me paraît essentiel
dans la situation actuelle de notre pays
et vous voulez dire que ce n'est pas le
cas donc des autres syndicats comme
force ouvrière qui se retrouvent
paradoxalement plus à gauche que vous
dans cette affaire écoutez qu'est ce que
ça veut dire où se trouve l'intérêt des
salariés
vous avez c'est ça qui nous préoccupe
nous allons pas nous pourrions nous
déterminer en fonction d' apologie de
position des uns et des autres ce qui
nous préoccupe c'est la position
et les problèmes des salariés j'aurais
veut dire qu'il ya deux conceptions du
syndicalisme dans notre pays
première conception qui consiste à dire
on dénonce le gouvernement
on dénonce le patronat on dénonce les
autres organisations syndicales qui se
mouillent qui prennent des
responsabilités on est les plus beaux et
les meilleurs c'est une conception qui
n'est pas celle de la cfdt
oui alors il ya notre conception qui est
celle d'une organisation syndicale qui
n'a pas peur de prendre en compte les
évolutions les mutations des
transformations qui s'opèrent dans la
société et qui tente d'apporter des
réponses concrètes pour qu'effectivement
les salariés ne soient pas sacrifiés
pour que le chômage recule pour
qu'effectivement la marginalisation
régresse que nous soyons capables de
montrer aujourd'hui que le syndicalisme
et pas simplement de cause et sur les
problèmes de l'emploi qui n'est pas
simplement capable de faire des discours
mais qu'il est capable de poser des
actes pour créer les conditions
effectivement d'une autre conception de
la modernisation est ce que nous avons
également décidé au dans notre bureau
national aujourd'hui c'est donc de
relancer la négociation de branche
d'intervenir auprès des chambres
patronales et de créer les conditions
d'une mobilisation de l'ensemble des
salariés
il est important que le patronat là
aussi prenne ses responsabilités pour
caspar merci pour ce plaidoyer donc et
cette justification de la corde que vous
avez signé aujourd'hui une bonne
surprise et une embellie le déficit de
notre commerce extérieur a fondu le mois
dernier un demi milliard de francs 5
fois moins qu'en janvier une performance
due à une forte croissance des
exportations notamment produits
industriels civils et agro alimentaire
il faut ajouter que la douceur de
l'hiver à limiter la facture pétrolière
notons en passant que alcatel espère
vendre des centraux téléphoniques au
bangladesh
le président de ce pays termine ce soir
une visite officielle en france
des chiffres qui font peur et qui
mesurent les risques de l'échec scolaire
pour nos enfants
ils ne sont que 9% à savoir lire
convenablement à l'entrée en sixième
moins de 20% en troisième comment lutter
contre cette cause majeure de l'échec
scolaire et bien voici un recueil de
recettes
le rapport du recteur me l'ont accepté
hier par jelen jospin et qui recommande
entre autres que l'on procède dès la
rentrée prochaine
une évaluation des acquis en ce2 et en
sixième autre suggestion des modules de
formation continue de telles expériences
existent déjà il faut les généraliser
voyons avec serge me serais ce qui se
passe dans une école primaire publique
de puteaux avait monté à l'évidence il a
des difficultés
pas simple d'apprendre à lire à 6 ans
ici dans cette classe chaque élève
travaille à sa propre vitesse s'il bute
sur un mot il vient outre la première
partie du travail se fait d'une manière
traditionnelle avec les 27 élèves de la
classe très vite
l'institutrice repère les enfants qui
ont des preuves l'enfant qui va être en
difficulté va être facile devant les
cris il va attendre qu'on lui donne les
clefs et qu'on à la limite pour lui d'y
fonder chiffres pour lui le message ils
font pas et ne sera pas de chercher
l'information alors qu'un bon lecteur il
va tout de suite au potentiel comprendre
les enfants en difficulté reste au cours
de rattrapage et là chacun va travailler
à son propre rythme l'un des exercices
consiste à associer un mois une image
pour mieux le retenir
il faut aussi chercher l'erreur presque
un jeu sous la direction d'une
institutrice spécialisée pour elle dans
ses difficultés de lecture
les responsabilités sont multiples
situations sociales environnement
enseignements mais aussi les parents
attention je vous ai pas l'apprentissage
du langage se fait au sein de la famille
qui apprend à parler à son enfance et la
mère le père primordial innovation
importante dans cette école les enfants
cherchent des mots sur un ordinateur
c'est une aide presque un gadget mais il
est évident que la clé comme le souligne
le rapport migeon c'est de lire quel que
soit l'outil livres ou ordinateur
les professeurs du second degré n'ont
pas l'air de se rapprocher de la ligne
just naissent réunis en congrès à dijon
a durci le ton aujourd'hui élections des
maires aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de
municipalités mais me direz-vous c'était
dimanche dernier en fait les élections
ont été formalisées aujourd'hui par les
nouveaux conseils municipaux c'est ainsi
sans surprise que jacques chirac a été
élu maire de paris pour la troisième
fois et robert vigouroux maire de
marseille
a marseille la séance a été agitée et
jean paul goude a quitté la salle à lyon
michel noir a vu les choses en grand
un show à l'américaine que nous montre
bernard pradines aux émotions à la
lyonnaise
mais comme dans un film américain
l'ancien maire pendant 12 ans francisque
collomb pasly pouvoir à son jeune rival
comblé de succès michel noir souriant
sous les feux des projecteurs car la
cérémonie était retransmise sur tous les
écrans de télévision de l'hôtel de ville
pour un public d'amis répartis dans les
différents salons où la lumière des
lustres magnifique se mêlaient aux
reflets des écrans géants
les journalistes locaux ont menacé un
moment d'être écarté de tout cet apparat
avait réagi vivement en forçant tout
simplement mais avec bonhomie les portes
de la salle du conseil municipal le
maire a déclaré qu'il travaillerait au
service des lyonnais
c'était simple mais cette évidence a
beaucoup plu toute la salle a applaudi
michel noir est bien la nouvelle star de
lion nathan en passant que le socialiste
michel charzat battu de peu dimanche
dernier dans le 20e arrondissement de
paris michel charzat a déposé un recours
en annulation contre sont heureux rival
didier bariani élections encore les
prochaines européennes gérard longuet du
parti républicain n'est décidément pas
d'accord avec françois léotard si les
centristes font une liste séparée il se
met en dehors de l'idf at il déclaré à
valeurs actuelles
pas de réaction en tout cas au sein de
l'udf à l'offre de service de madame
simone veil qui s'est proposé pour
conduire la liste centriste
de son côté jean marie le pen dénonce le
cynisme du rpr et de l'udf qui
prétendent seul incarner l'opposition
nationale dit-il élections toujours mais
cette fois en union soviétique
dimanche prochain 184 millions de
citoyens choisiront leurs députés selon
un processus complexe et à filtrage qui
continuent de privilégier les orthodoxes
mais pour les partisans des réformes et
pour mikhaïl gorbatchev c'est bien le
début la mort ce d'une nouvelle vie
politique à moscou georges bartoli
on peut faire un grand reproche à ces
élections c'est que les cages sort
députés qui vont être élus ne seront pas
vraiment des députés mais de simples
grands électeurs dont le travail sera
d'élire une seconde assemblée plus
restreinte qui elle va vraiment sujet
est délibéré en revanche ces élections
ont l'inestimable avantage d'éveiller
l'intérêt du soviétique moyens pour la
vie politique car il constate que il ya
en général deux ou plusieurs candidats
par sièges à pourvoir et que même si ces
deux candidats sont tous les deux
membres du parti communiste
ils débattent vraiment de problèmes
concrets qui le concerne lui
le citoyen et puis ces élections ont un
intérêt particulier dans la périphérie
de l'union soviétique les pays baltes le
caucase là où les propos des candidats
ont souvent un parfum tout à fait non
conformiste c'est à dire en clair qu'il
demande plus d'autonomie pour les
populations locales
chaque candidat même contestataires a le
droit de s'exprimer c'est bien normal
rights watch hrw
les pousses du numéro un soviétique qui
ne parlent jamais politique intérieure
en tout cas publiquement même combat de
chauffailles ci contribuent à
l'effervescence pour ce que vit
aujourd'hui en recevant un groupe
d'étudiants américains et soviétiques
comme le disais à l'instant georges
bortoli c'est vrai que si on attend de
ces élections
aucune remise en cause du système
politique on observera bien sûr avec
intérêt les résultats dans les
républiques de l'union agité par les
mouvements nationalistes
gilles rabin et jean-marie le quartier
ont pu et c'est une première
se rendre à bakou la capitale de
l'azerbaïdjan
toujours en état d'exception depuis
novembre dernier
leur reportage
ce vendredi est jour de fête religieuse
en azerbaïdjan une fête autorisé pour la
première fois depuis 70 ans
à
mais soldats de moscou ton peut faire
oublier le couvre-feu et les blessures
ouvertes laisser à des massacres de l'an
dernier la grande peur d algérie c'est
qu'à cause des pogroms le karabagh ne
devienne la palestine les arméniens
j'ai confiance l'activité de nos
dirigeants
je vois la situation qui se normalise
je vois que les arméniens qui étaient
partis reviennent aujourd'hui avec ou
des arméniens peuvent venir si ce marché
par exemple bien sûr normalement sans
risquer de se faire traiter de sale
arménien au ghsr arménienne aucune
antenne au petit déjeuner dans le bureau
du numéro 1 de bêtes
le premier secrétaire du parti viry
m'hamid of my head of mohamed en russe
il a été donné par gorbatchev après les
pogroms pour remettre de l'ordre dans
les affaires de la république et les
candidats aux élections
velits manier d'offres se plaint du
temps perdu avec la querelle du karabagh
cette affaire nous dit il paralyse la
vie politique depuis des mois en
azerbaïdjan d'ailleurs fait part à une
réunion électorale sonné avec moi vous
verrez on ne parlera que de ça
si les politesses électorale du zoo en
russe dès qu'on aborde le coeur du débat
politique
tout le monde s'exprime en azéri la
première question est ce premier avec
une âpreté toute orientale concerne
effectivement le karabagh je suis né là
bas 17 électeurs c'est ma terre ma vraie
patrie pour moi le karabagh c'est une
terre sainte
qu'est ce que vous allez répondre dans
l'avenir à tous ceux qui vous disent la
main sur le coeur que karabagh et une
personne mais affichaient leur dirai que
je suis puisse faire sainte aussi pour
les arméniens et que nous sommes
condamnés à trouver une solution parce
que nous sommes obligés et ce vivre
ensemble
aucun risque pourtant les arméniens ne
reviennent pas qu'il y avait 250 mille
fidèles dans la capitale d'azerbaidjan
après les pogroms
il n'en reste plus que 25000 lévesque et
c'est diacre se sont enfuis et le
dernier prêtre arménien de bakou veille
sur une église vide garé des nuitées
jour par la milice de moscou trêve de
courte durée aujourd'hui à beyrouth
les bombardements ont repris ce soir
entre chrétiens et musulmans avaient par
les syriens
dix ans jour pour jour après comme des
vides
une réunion au sommet aura lieu demain à
ismaïlia en egypte entre le président
moubarak
yasser arafat et le roi hussein de
jordanie super effervescence dans les
milieux judiciaires belges
un avocat a été arrêté et inculpé la
nuit dernière dans le cadre de l'enquêté
sur l'enlèvement de paul vanden
boeynants hervé brusini cette lettre
date du 15 décembre 86 elle est signée
patrick patrick haemers ce ravisseur
présumé de vdb à l'époque hammers est en
prison il parle d'une visite que lui a
rendu son avocat vanderijst il m'a
expliqué certaines choses yammer sans
autre précision amr c'est son avocat
étaient amis depuis bien longtemps
mais ces relations sont peut-être allés
beaucoup plus loin coïncidence le
cabinet de vendeur est éminent juriste
est situé dans le même immeuble que
celui de paul vanden boeynants ce mais
surtout lorsque l'ancien premier
ministre belge était détenu dans cette
ville-là du touquet lorsqu'il y négocier
lui-même le montant de sa rançon
les ravisseurs ont à plusieurs reprises
téléphoné à val de reuil les rencontres
auraient même eu lieu entre les hommes
dames earth et l'avocat autre élément
troublant les empreintes digitales de
vanderijst ont été retrouvés dans l'une
des planques de patrick haemers ici même
pour les enquêteurs l'avocat pourrait
être le cerveau de l'affairé vdb
remarquable conseiller financier il
aurait même conçu les filières qui ont
servi à blanchir l'argent de la rançon
une partie des 8 millions de francs
français seraient passés par cette
société de papier gimmick une piste
conduire mm vers la france
pour l'heure dans sa prison ventes de
rolls nie tout en bloc au palais de
justice de bruxelles
ils sont nombreux à se déclarer
stupéfait par les accusations portées
contre l'avocat retards files d'attentes
fouilles plusieurs aéroports européens
en état d' alerte pour les fêtes de
pâques
les américains estiment qu'un
détournement d'avions pourraient avoir
lieu
remy roche les recommandations de
l'administration fédérale américaine de
l'aviation sont prises très au sérieux
dans les aéroports de londres
il faut dire que la polémique se
poursuit en grande bretagne où l'on
accuse le gouvernement d'avoir négligé
précisément de tels avertissements
signifier peu avant l'explosion du
boeing de la twh à lockerbie
conséquence d'interminables files
d'attentes pour cause de fouilles
renforcées et des retards de près d'une
heure au décollage
autant d'inconvénients plutôt bien
acceptée par des passagers d'accord pour
ne rien sacrifier à leur sécurité était
d' alerte également à bruxelles au moins
pour toute la durée des vacances de
pâques
à paris enfin on indique qu' aucune
mesure spéciale a été mise en place dans
les aéroports d'orly et de roissy
charles de gaulle il est vrai qu'après
l'attentât de lockerbie
les compagnies aériennes américaines
avaient déjà très sensiblement renforcé
leurs dispositifs de contrôle des
bagages et des passagers
joyeuses pâques peu de monde aujourd'hui
à jérusalem pour la procession du
vendredi saint et héros vatican le pape
jean paul ii avait commencé à célébrer
pâques en [ __ ] les pieds des apôtres
et hyper
comme le veut la tradition le pape jean
paul ii à laver hier les deux jeunes
faitre de pays différents
commémorant ainsi l' acte d'humilité du
fils à la veille de son martyre le pape
a ouvert les quatre jours les plus
importants du calendrier de l'église
catholique romaine
deux chemins de croix à paris pour
commémorer la passion et la mort du
christ plusieurs milliers de fidèles ont
suivi le cardinal jean marie lustiger
sur la butte montmartre
l'archevêque de paris a porté lui même
la croix tout au long des 14 stations du
calvaire avant de dire une prière sur le
parvis de la basilique des champs
elysées à l'église saint pierre de
chaillot deuxième chemin de croix à
l'appel de la communauté charismatique
de les manuels escorté par les
chevaliers de l'ordre du saint sépulcre
des chrétiens du liban et du sud est
asiatique
on portait une croix de deux mètres
cinquante de haut
la relation et crucifixions philippines
la seule nation d'asie à majorité
chrétienne
malgré les appels à la modération de
l'église des centaines de fidèles se
sont plages et les onze d'entre eux se
sont fait crucifier en public
il est vrai que ces manifestations
attirent de plus en plus de curieux les
poches pleines de devises pour la
première fois le ministère du tourisme
philippe pas à financer les cérémonies
justice n'est pas vengeance
c'est le titre de son dernier livre
c'est aussi la maxime d'une vie d'une
longue vie consacrée aux témoignages et
à la mémoire
simon wiesenthal 80 ans passés
autrichien continue de poursuivre les
responsables du génocide nazi
il sera tout à l'heure l'invité de
bernard pivot apostrophes league epl
beau mais jan cornet ils ont rencontré
il ya quelques jours à vienne
dissimulés derrière cette scène biblique
du centre de vienne la réminiscence
d'une communauté détruite la rue des
juifs laâyoune dundas lui wiesenthal
il est revenu après ma pause parce qu'il
est autrichien parce que ce qu'ils ont
envoyés dans les camps était autrichien
y compris hitler c'est d'ici qu'il a
décidé de les traquer l'immeuble de son
centre de documentation a été construit
sur les ruines de l'ancien siège de la
gestapo à vienne un rendez vous de
l'histoire qui s'affiche du bout des
lèvres pour naviguer dans ce capharnaüm
de cartes de dossiers de livres
wiesenthal n'a que sa mémoire
phénoménale la dérision des moyens les
menaces n'ont jamais émoussé son ardeur
aujourd'hui à 80 ans il veut qu un nazi
plus que tout autre réponde de ses
crimes
celui dont l'extradition est demandée
par la france à la syrie aloïs brunner
thunder bay et brunner est l'inventeur
de la collaboration juive avec l'ennemi
robert bonner était l'homme de confiance
d'hitler mais tout est dans ce dossier
le chantage l'utilisation des structures
communautaires pour accélérer le
massacre des juifs de france devienne de
salonique
tout est là y compris une photo du faux
passeports de brunner son adresse et son
téléphone à damas déchets rien fait les
syriens disent qu'ils ne le connaissent
pas et bien voilà un jeune habitant qui
l'a rencontré et qui lui a parlé
et puis cet énorme dossier menguelet que
wiesenthal refuse de classe et il n'a
pas la preuve irréfutable de la mort du
médecin d'auschwitz est liée à
l'attitude suspecte de la famille sy
wiesenthal nouveau leur laisser aucun
répit
il a la liste de tous les officiers ss
du lieutenant au général les 120000 la
plus longue liste de criminels du monde
mais qu'il est difficile de contraindre
un pays à feuilleter sans cesse les
pages noires de son histoire
c'est dire que wiesenthal est restés
longtemps isolés à vienne hitler dit il
assassine et moralement 2 génération
d'allemands et d'autrichiens la
troisième génération
les jeunes eux n'hésitent pas à
l'aborder dans la rue pour lui demander
des informations sur le nazisme
les gens me reconnaissent que mais de la
fausse monnaie par la force du temps la
chasse aux criminels nazis appartiendra
bientôt à l'histoire
après quarante ans de lutte obstinée
simon wiesenthal est l'une des
consciences de l'autriche
le livre de ses mémoires est aujourd'hui
dans les vitrines des libraires de
vienne et simon wiensenthal en parlera
donc tout à l'heure avec bernard pivot
apostrophes la régie renault est de
retour en formule 1 et redémarre sur les
chapeaux de roues sont moteurs qui
équipent l'écurie williams a réussi
aujourd'hui le meilleur temps des
premiers essais qualificatifs du grand
prix du brésil qui aura lieu dimanche
avec la voiture de ricardo paez après
avoir abandonné les moteurs turbo la
régie revient en force
lionel chamoulaud frank williams devant
sa formule 1 rend hommage au moteur
renault franchement de mon point de vue
le matin c'est déjà un niveau très très
bon ça veut dire qu'on va travailler
très vite par le dos d'un ghetto soir
un bon travail car cette williams
heureux nous fait partie des favorites
de la saison le constructeur français ne
veut pas raté son retour le 7 juin 88
renault dévoile son arme ce v10 pour un
retour après deux ans d'absence cette
fois la régie veut un titre renault
c'est le constructeur qui a amené le
turbo à la formule en 1977
le palmarès du moteur 140 grands prix
courus 50 pole position 20 victoires
avec jabouille
arnaud prost et senna mais cette année
le turbo c'est fini la régime est au pc
résultats avec ceux des 10 avait dix
comme honda
certainement que dans un premier temps
la comparaison sera difficile
renault est donc associés pour trois ans
avec l'écurie williams peut-être la
régie équipera telle une autre équipe
l'année prochaine grâce à son passé de
compétition renault progresse à grands
pas la régie revient aussi avec une
autre mentalité
la formule 1 c'est également l'occasion
d'affronter les autres grands
constructeurs mondiaux
renault ne l'oublient pas les pronostics
de pierre de bresse pour demain saint
cloud dans le prix rtl le 3 8 le vin le
13 le 4 le 1 le 12 et le 16 dans un
instant laurent cabrol va vous parler du
temps henri sannier vous présentera
notre dernier journal à 22h50 vos rendez
vous pour la formation ce week-end
daniel bilalian philippe gassot sous la
douche férule de betty dur on est bien
sur la scène anglaise avec bernard rapp
voilà très bon week end lundi à 20h vous
retrouverez avec claude à la semaine
prochaine et joyeuses pâques